so we'll do this panda spot this morning
there may be a consolation this
afternoon if so I stepped in and say
that I could do the second part of my
tutorial but if you've already done
pandas this is not for you and yeah it's
really pandas for beginners and then
yeah maybe scikit-learn this afternoon
maybe Delta I send an email message to
the organizers to know so like I don't
want you to lose your time so if yeah
once again and so you won't need much
this morning anyway so here like even
this more like for this morning you
won't need scikit-learn yellow brick I
don't think I've there I'm not sure I
remember but yeah these are the main
thing that you only like pandas and
Jupiter
[Music]
oops I could do that
did everyone already use Jupiter not
books or did some of you never used it
which is not a problem but just it's
good for everyone okay so for those who
just arrived outside again I'll I will
just have the time to depend a spot this
morning and it spanned us for beginners
so if you've already using pandas it's
probably useless for you and yeah maybe
[Music]
[Music]
and please let me know if you need any
help to start a Jupiter nod book because
you've never done it yep and it's not a
big deal we're just gonna use it like
for one or two cells
so did you did you install a nook did
you install condor on your in your
virtual environment or not
yeah but then each time you do a virtual
environment you need to reinstall
everything you just have Python in your
virtual environment so you don't have
gone I don't well I don't think you I
don't know yeah I think I think you can
people it's not anyway
[Music]
[Music]
yeah my virtual environment are not
[ __ ] da so I go I'm not sure about
that tip should work as well if you
don't have your breakdown don't worry
I'm not even sure I use it in the first
notebook and even though it would be in
one or two cells so it's not a big deal
[Music]
[Music]
the yellow brick is not we're not gonna
use yellow brick this morning so just
know it's another library yeah it's
another library it's not thought of
scikit-learn so just before we give a
gear a start for the last one who
arrived we're just gonna do the pandas
spot this morning because an hour and a
half is not long enough to do pandas and
scikit-learn and if there is a
constellation this afternoon I stepped
into to do the second part but I don't
know yet so maybe maybe not we'll see so
everyone get a get the opportunity to
download or like you don't really need
to clone download is enough and open a
Jupiter notebook or ji tell me if you
have issue the man went well okay
okay so I'll just super quickly present
myself so my name is Sandra limpet oh
I'm French live in London work as a data
scientist at Cuba insurance and I'm a
former teacher so hopefully my skill are
useful today
so if please let me know if not everyone
is there another notebook open so we're
gonna we're gonna start with the first
notebook and that's mainly what we'll
have the time to do this morning which
is data wrangling with Python we spend a
sari which is built on Python
everyone knows once again how do you do
not book works globally or not at all
yeah so it's sort of in P let me show
that again and then if you go to my
where is my mouse if you go to if you
look for something P then you will find
like I managed to have it it's the first
one on the veranda on my home page so
like you just Google something P github
you should find it easily so like once
again on the installation side you will
need Jupiter pandas and matplotlib maybe
Seabourn not scikit-learn not yellow
brick
so like don't get worried issue
Coenen store you're breaking all good
okay so let me go back to the first
notebook so if you don't know Kegel
that's a website like that's a data
science competition website but there
are also lots of open source data set
that you can find one advice is even if
it's on Kegel if I were you I would
check that it is open source and what's
the condition to use the data and also
remember that we're and in Europe and
it's not because data is open source
that you have the right to do whatever
you want because GDP are so that's an
advice so this one is definitely open
source so we're going going to use the
Titanic data set which is a really
classic one when you start to work with
pandas and with scikit-learn
so you can find like I put the link so
that you can you can have a look look at
it but I've already put it in the folder
so no worries
so first things we're going to do is
import pandas yeah you'll see like most
if not all the cells are empty and my
way of working is for us to fill it
together because I believe that when you
type you'll learn more than just running
cells so we're gonna improvement us as
PD some people do that's a super common
way to import pandas some people just
use pandas completely like the fool
pandas name it depends you do whatever
you want as you know another thing that
I have to warn you about it's it's my
French laptop when I usually work with
an English one so there will probably
lots of misspelling with Q's instead of
A's so that's usually the fun side of
changing laptops okay you could import
numpy as and peope
it's already within pandas so you can
also do NP equals PD dot and P and you
will have loaded numpy the first thing
we're gonna do now the next thing we're
gonna do now is to import a data frame
so we're gonna call it DF and to do that
we're going to the CSV file so we're
going to do pandas dot read underscore
CSV and we'll put the path that's the
other problem there are the Q's and the
brackets and the codes so it's in the
data folder then there is a titanic
folder and the first one is called train
dot CSV okay there is two DS
yes yes is it big enough or not do you
want me to make it bigger or yeah yeah
okay you're welcome
I don't know if I can move that okay so
there is another data frame which is the
holdout so we're gonna same import it so
pandas don't read CSV crap and it's in
the same folder and it's called like
this the only difference is that it's
called test dot CSV data and test dot
CSV so when you're doing data science
what you want is to have holdout so part
of your data that you're not gonna look
at until the really end at the end of of
your process to check that your
prediction are good okay but you don't
want to look at it you don't want to be
biased you don't want to see what it
looks like you don't want to see if it
looks like the rest of your data if we
add a time series we would for example
take the first two years in our train in
our training set and you know all doubt
denied the last six months or something
like that and we would train on the
first two years and we will keep the
holdout
the last six months and like untouched
and we don't want to look at it and then
see if our prediction our predictive
model works fine on deal on this Lux
last two and six months sorry okay so
same for your data preparation you don't
want to be biased you don't want to say
us here there is something in my holdout
that I should pay attention to know if
there is a change in the data you should
know about it because in real life you
won't know about a new dirt a change
that it's that is coming okay so there
is in the Jupiter notebook you can look
for help so if we lo if you want to look
at the help of the first function that
we use soap and our with the treat CSV
we can just put a question mark and then
write your phone our function
we'd CSV and it will open down there the
app and give you all the parameters that
you can use in your function you can
also use shift tab when you're on the
function oops
normally here and you will have it here
and you can just have the same thing
here okay
I just put so that's that's something
that I found on the Cagle websites so
you have the data dictionary so that's
the different columns that we will have
in our data frame so we'll have
different information about the
passengers ma first if they survived or
not that's what we would try to predict
with the wisdom model so that's the with
your target so first thing we're gonna
do is to have a look at the first five
rows
using the head method so our data frame
is called gf and we're going to do D F
dot heads and by default it will show us
the first five rows we can also decide
to look just us at one if we want to
just forget the first row at 20 or
whatever we can we can pass it a
different number so similarly there is a
tail method so same if we want to look
at it because we want to only look at
the last three rows we can again use our
question mark then does dot data frame
because it's applied to a data frame so
if you don't put that you won't get the
help you were looking for and so Sammy
will tell us like the default value is
five so if we do D F dot l3 we will have
only three up sorry I should have closed
that we sure we will only see three the
last three rows sorry then we can look
at the shape of our data frame so we can
use the shape attribute and it will
return the number of rows and the number
of columns of our data frame
another useful one is D F dot info the
method not the the attribute with
brackets and it will return the name of
the different columns of her data frame
and it will also give us the type and
the number of non nil values in the
colon so like we can see that most of
them have lots of non news and we have
like cabin that is not well filled an
age that is not completely filled after
that if we want to have a look at the
numerical columns we can also use the
described method to see the distribution
of these collins so DF describe and it
will return the Condamine the standard
deviation the minimum the first and
third quartile the median than the
maximum of the different numerical
columns here i put a note so like there
is another library which is called
pandas profiling which is quite useful
as well but it could take super long to
run depending on your size the size of
your data frame because he will give you
but it will give you more information on
each column for example
knowing that you have a colon that is
completely filled
so no non values that's good but if they
are all the same it's not really useful
if they're all equal to zero
well you'd like to you'd like to know
that and panache profiling will tell you
that it will it will give you more
information but like I didn't want to
install that and to run that but like
once again big data frame it takes lots
of time so if you want like what I
usually do is I use it on certain
columns and not on all like all the
columns of the data frame or you make it
run and you just go do something else
that's another option you can UK you
have to install it
that's another library it's called
pandas profiling but it's not in pandas
so you'll have to pip install it or to
condense you can probably condi install
it as well after that we can get a list
of the column names so DF dot Collins
and if we want to put in a list we use
two lists because otherwise if you have
a too long list you wouldn't see
everything oops to list what is that ah
yeah we thought on this koi was correct
the first time and it's that I have a mm
that's better like that okay so that's
our twelve or so Collins
so after that I will use the option to
display a smaller number of rules than
the default one so if we want to lose
that the default number of rules you do
pandas dot options to display dot max
underscore rows and it will tell you
that the default one is sixty and what I
want to do now is to set it at fifteen
so you just give it the value fifteen so
now we will maximum see 15 rows when
well 15 rows will be displayed
okay subsetting now so there are
different ways to subset the data frame
the first one that we will see is just
you get a colon so if we want to look at
the crap sorry and crowd at the big
class :
so we'll just we will just pass the
class into square brackets and we will
see the first 15 value well not the
first 15 value sorry but we'll see 15
values the first and the last ones of
the P class : and here also at the end
tells us once again the length of the
colon and the type of the data so after
that if we want to look at the 12
observation there are two ways to do
that either we use I lock or dot I lock
or dot lock
so here it's gonna be the same because
the index and the position are the same
I stand for integer not index so it's
going to be the position of your rows or
your colon when we work with it here
it's the same so we're gonna just you
pass the number 11 to of the 12th value
the toffs row and so if we do a DF dot
lock with 11 that's gonna give us the
same thing exactly oops
so after that if you want to look at the
name of the last three observation this
time we're going to work on rows and on
colon at the same time so if we use a
lock for good so DF dot I lock first
we're gonna give it the rows position so
we can start because again its position
we can start at minus three and tell the
end and for where was it the name so
we'll have to look the name is zero one
two three so the third column the first
column sorry so is integer three and we
will have the last three observations
and we'll get their names with dot lock
will have to give it an index so the
first index we want is a delayed until
the end and we can pass it's just the
name of the colon and we will get the
same thing
it pull it shouldn't work because the
thing is here the 88 is the index it
doesn't have index minus three so it's
probably starting at zero and gives you
everything low I guess ya know for me
like I didn't I didn't try but normally
with luck you use index so index of the
rose index so name of the Cullen and the
other one it's all position so you can
try but like I don't think it will
return you anything if you give try
three because it doesn't know : call
three so after that it all depends what
you want to do with your color and if
you want to do a loop and need an
integer in your loop and then then it
sits well it really depends it's
possibly easier if you want to use the
full position of the root use that but
then you have to make sure that the
position of your Cullen is the correct
one yeah it depends on the situation so
both are useful okay finally you have a
look at the age and fare of the
forty-fifth the first and the eights
observation so if you're there already
you can give it a try
so one will be with a lock one will be
with luck
you have to check the position of the
agent fare column in the in dialog sorry
which is integer is position lock its
labels so labels for the Collins and
index for the rows so what did I say
forty thieves and then the first and
then the aides so we can just pass it's
a list yeah a list of positions and then
same for the Collins we said what agent
fare five five and nine I'm I've worked
okay and so for look the same least
forty four zero seven and men age and
fare
so it depends what you've done if if
you've done if you d f dots I log if you
pass it just like that forty four zero
seven
well it doesn't understand because like
for him the 44 corresponds to the rows
the zero to the colon and then the seven
it doesn't know like if you pass it this
way it works you have to pass it a lists
so that he knows that he has to look at
this list of things know it's eight
their index so like its label for colon
index for rows and the other one is
integer I for integers of position for
booze yes I have no idea but that's a
good question anyone knows no I don't
know if there is a difference in speed
or some it really did like I use it I
use one or the other depending on my
needs
yeah
[Music]
okay another thing you have to pay
attention to is I lock those I lock and
dot lock doesn't work the same exactly
so if you use I lock the end value in
the in the wrench is included or not
sorry I don't
I forgot how I started my sentence so I
don't know how to finish it so if we
want to look at I don't know like the
file like the rows from five to ten if
you do it with lock you can see that the
row with index ten is included if you
use the same thing with I lock he will
stop at nine
oh good oh you have a question okay so
we're going to clean different columns
the first one so we're gonna label this
one this X : so the first one we're
gonna look at is the count of the
different value in this column so we
want to look at this X : so we do DF
square brackets and then we pass like in
general the name of our the : we want to
work with so like once again like it's
the same as I don't remember who has the
question but like if we wanted to look
at two Collins we would have to pass a
list of : so like we would have two pair
of square brackets and we're gonna do a
value cone so dot value underscore
counts and we will see 577 male 353
female so one way to mobilize this : to
change that into into numbers don't have
male and female of zeros and one is to
use a map function so we're gonna create
sorry a dictionary so you call it the
way you want for me dico make sense
because that's a short way to set
dictionary in french but i don't know if
that makes sense to everyone
we're gonna do other is at least another
one so that's why i give it a name
corresponding to the :
and so we're gonna give it were on my
colleague brackets
[Music]
male the value 0 and female the value 1
oops
okay and we're gonna apply this
dictionary to our colon and we're gonna
create a new colon doing that to create
on your colon there is it's super easy
you just plus the name of your new colon
to your data frame so this one is going
to be called sex lab for label yeah I
know I made that make to make one of my
friend laugh and I'm I'm videoed saying
sex lab so like please think of me I
don't care it's fun anyway so we're
gonna do so our first : so the sex : and
we're gonna do a dot map and we're just
gonna pass it the dictionary so and we
have a new colon created that simple and
we're gonna check the values that we
have in our code on your new : so you
can redo value cons and apply it to you
the sex lab :
yep got e and we can see in this : we
have zeros instead of Mel and one
instead of female usually I know that
like you can mobilise like there are
other way to do toolable eyes collins um
I like to decide the way it is labeled
so usually I use a dictionary but there
are other ways to do it for example for
me for the embark Olin what I wanted to
do is to get the labels in order where
people went on the boat so like what did
I do
one will be so that's why I looked in
which like what was the first stop so
sometime will be left labeled one after
that we are what shabu will be labeled
two and Queenstown will be labeled three
[Music]
so first we're going to look at not the
number not the count but the proportion
of the different value in the unbought :
so embarked and so the only thing that
you have to do we're gonna do a value
count but we're going to pass it
normalize equal to equal through troops
sorry normalize equal true and instead
of apps that you counts
instead of returning the number for its
value like account for its value it
returns a proportion so same if you
already there you cannot start EULA
belies the : so we can we're gonna
create a dictionary so Tico and oops
underscore would be better so I said so
for s s will be 1 C 2 and Q 3 not too
far
so after that I said C 2 Q 3 and same
we're gonna create a new : embarked lab
and to do that we're gonna we're gonna
map or dictionary to the embarked : I
didn't that's a mistake thinks it should
be a capital s Thanks
I don't think so no no I don't think you
can do that and Sam you can check the
proportion but this time I'd like to see
the proportion including the non values
because there are some non values in
this column so on top of giving it
normalizing for true we're going to pass
it drop n equal false because by default
she drops the ten and values
[Music]
and we see that the values are all a bit
different than the previous one because
this time we have included the non
values yes why is the label sorry
because there are none values none is a
float it's it's account so like these
are the values that you have in your
Collins it's not yeah but my point is
was that because there is a non value
none is afloat so that changed all or
color like even even if we give it
integers because of the nuns it turns it
it turns everything into fruit and so
talking about the non values we want to
replace them with zeros so we can do
that so we do so if we just do that I'll
show you DF I'm bout lab unlocked lab
whoops
so if we just do Phil na which is the
the function to you replace all the non
values with something so I want to feel
in there with zeros if I just run that
it will return me the Colin with the na
field but you wouldn't you won't it
won't replace the na in the original
data frame so there is I believe in
place equal troop I've heard from core
developer that it will be the pre-k but
appreciated more deprecated I don't know
how its said at one point so I take the
abbot's not to use it and you just react
that to the original column except that
an underscore would be better and so
this time I replaced my colon and bought
lab with the N bar club with the NS
replaced with zeros so now like Sam if
you want to check your your value count
instead of the Nanji will have the res
so like talking about the holdout
originally like imagine that they were
forced for sport where people embarked
but in our training we just have three
we want to be it once again by a stand
know that in the holdout there will be a
force one because right now I'm not
supposed to know about it because I'm
not I'm not supposed to know anything
about the holdout so I do my prep on the
training with what I know about the
training sets and then I will have to
adapt and I will work only with what I
know on the training set ok so the age :
we can plot things directly with pandas
so we're gonna first use the magic
command matplotlib in line so that's
from the Djibouti notebook matplotlib in
line and then we're gonna do DF age dot
East oops and that should be there and
we have a histogram so okay there is no
title no no labels nothing but it was
simple and easy of course you can do
better than not I'm not the best at
visualization so and I I use it rarely I
have to say I know that now you can
change because and use other stuff than
matplotlib so if you can if you want to
use Seabourn you can set Seabourn as the
default
[Music]
plot like things to plot library to use
to plot yes that allows you to just plot
that in a in a in a notebook you don't
you don't need to import no idea
I didn't import it I don't need to
import it like it's it's a magic coming
from the Jupiter notebook there are
other magic commands but this one allows
you to plot directly without importing
my part lib or anything and it just
displays it's it's it's the magic
commands of a % before them you have
like different you can also use like the
common line or some stuff like that if
you look for that you will out yeah so
time per like allows you to time your
your running time in the running time of
your cell
so the matplotlib one that we just used
load is quite useful as well allows you
to load something that is in a different
file system I don't use often yeah that
that's order and there is there there is
one that allows you I think it's a I
don't remember to use the common line
there is one she used to come and mine
as well usually I use a oh yeah yeah
it's not a magic come on you're right
yeah
Yuli I open a terminal because you'd
like it same like said you can open
terminal so I prefer to open a terminal
and do everything in terminal
yeah yeah yeah I think there is a
difference with bit when you use it and
when you don't don't ask me what again
like mud but there is a difference I
believe okay I'll look for it I know
there yeah I'll look for it again find
the number of observation with none in
the H :
so there is if you just want that you
can just use the is null function so DF
we said age so crap if we just do is
null it will return a list of boolean's
telling you telling us if it's if it's
null or not if the value is not as no
not if we want the number we just have
to some butts and it will return the
number of true values okay
so what we're going to do next is to
replace the missing value this 177
missing values using the median but not
the median of all the Colin but the
median puppy class because it was it was
true then it's still true now like
depending on on your p class usually you
don't have the same age first class are
usually not the same age done first
class third class sorry so I decided and
like once again yes like the nun in
pandas pandas is built on numpy so it's
it's a non pas it's a empty dot none so
it's that as we said it's a float no
like same that's more Pisan thing than I
been dusting I think Knoll is like just
an object I will have to check it but
that would be the type would be
different but like in a pandas in pandas
you wouldn't have no you would have nuns
yeah yeah yeah it's cool like that there
because you could have also when you
have dead time Colin I didn't put
anything with daytime I think but then
you have it's not nine none it's n
eighty so not a time and then if you use
even all that works as well okay so
we're gonna do a pivot table so we're
gonna give a name to this pivot table so
age underscore medium-well pepper median
equals D F dot P what underscore table
and so we want
the median of the H :
or index is the P class : that's not
correct index equal P class and the
function we want to aggregate with so a
func is median so if we want to overlook
where are my at our pivot table it looks
like that so the median age for the
first class is 37 second class 29 and
third class 24 and once again because
there are nuns in the H :
that's why we have floats so after that
what I wanted to do is to replace the
nun values and left the non value sorry
in the H :
with these medians what I've done is not
super is not really beautiful but I
didn't find another way to do it and I
wanted to use my pivot table and not
just do a pivot table like that there
might be nicer way to do it so what I've
done is that I applied a function to two
Collins
so so I want to work with the Agent P
class :
so once again like what we said earlier
the the two pair of square brackets are
necessary otherwise it wouldn't
understand what we're talking about and
we're gonna apply a lambda function so
if you're new to Python and don't know
lambda function dots down below like
just type it and now we'll be fine
so what we want you do yes sorry thanks
for reminding me
yeah yeah but I don't know I've never
done how'd you do it control space B
control shift B okay so that's one way
still better that's something if you
live in nope if you live in that is good
oh cool no thank you
that's probably better in the back um
[Music]
learning something new every day that's
cool okay so what I want and that's here
that was not fully convenient to do I
want to take the median age
corresponding to my p class and if I do
that I also have to look for the value
because otherwise you will just return
um it won't return what's inside the
cell like not it's not exactly a cell
but like you won't return exactly what's
inside the cell so if we want to do that
we have to do a dot values with a it's
better and a zero like I have to pass it
zero because it returned a lists even if
there is only one thing so I want to do
that if the edge is null and I still in
my under function else I want to
otherwise I want to keep the age yeah
and access equal one otherwise he will
work under gross and then you can do
like a value contour like something to
check that you have no nuns or you can
do oh no I'm sorry plot a histogram of
the age : and then we'll see that it's a
little bit different from the previous
one we've done this two times
[Music]
and if you look at the previous one it's
a little bit different we have more
value around like 2030 because it
corresponds to the 177 like they were
what 24 would have been replaced by
either 24 27 hour with its search seven
or something like that
okay another will create other columns
so we're gonna create a colon with the
number of all the member of the family
if you look at the information about the
data set that I put there so we have
sibs per is that the siblings and the
spool the spouse and we have porch with
his parent and children so we're gonna
use this once these two wants to know
how many other people from the family
that were on the boat and to do that
that's super easy you can just add two
columns so same if you just add the
columns you won't create anything so
we're going to create a new colon called
family and we're just going to add the
two columns we were talking about which
are sieve as base sibling and spouse
plus oops
the parent and children and I can have a
look doing a value count okay the next
one it was more to show you that another
thing that we could do so this one I
called social so like because the the in
a family : you have other members of the
family but you don't have the person
themselves so I wanted to just add the
person so this one I called socio and
what we can do is so I'm gonna put
brackets because we're going to do two
things so we can add the person
themselves to the family : and to do
that oops with a Y would be better you
can just do a plus one and you will add
one to all your Collin to each its value
of your colon and then if you multiply
by the class the
Class B first class it will take them
one to one the first one x the first
like the first family plus one x the
first P class and so on so we will do it
line by line
untie me will give you like different
values like honestly this one is more
like an excuse to show you that to show
that what we can do but it was more like
when in the family members you have
everyone so there would be my family
members but not me
counted anything so I added one because
like I'm still part of the family so
yeah and multiplied by a class because
whatever it's just an example to show
things that we can do with columns so
here we can see that we have like yet
definitely different values okay so
another thing we can do is to instead of
looking at the head for example of your
data frame is look at the sample it's
it's good I can go down yep sorry I
think it does that row by row I don't
know it gives you the value I don't know
what it does
because it returned I think it's more
less returning the column yeah I think
it's just the column if we do that no
it's not the : yeah I don't yeah it is
the colon zero zero six one two yeah it
seems that yeah yeah yeah exactly like
if I if I just look at the color and you
have the same thing it tells you that
it's a Mets method my honor
it returns information about the method
I think not about the right yeah yeah
okay so oh yeah was on the samples so
sometime it's more interesting to other
a random sample of your data either to
make sure that the first five rows are
not have not something specific in it
that you can see different different
rows at the different place in the in
the data and sometime it's interesting
to play with the random state to to see
different cases so if we want to do that
DF so we're gonna look at the cabin
Cullen and we do dot sample by default
it will just return you one row I don't
know what the random state is by default
or if you change its time
it does it say it Rondon state none so
it's probably changing each time so so
you can either put the bracket at the
beginning or you do shift tab and then
you use the plus here to extend it this
one to stool or oh no this one puts you
it put it in the back so first thing
we're gonna pass it is the number of
sample that we want so 15 and I like to
give you a random States because
sometime you will see something
interesting and if you want to reproduce
it it's good to have your random state
or if you want like one of your
colleagues you look at the same rose
same good to have a random state here
and so you can see we have like random
indexes and the and the corresponding
values of the cabin cullen okay so what
we're gonna do is create a deck Cullen
with only the first the first letter
here
okay so deck yeah so new : called deck
we're gonna apply a lambda function to
the cabin : so same with you but like
this time it's easier because we have
just one column so the function will be
simply R so if X is a float meaning that
it's gonna be a nun so if I could have
done maybe is no not sure is instance X
float then I want to keep it I want to
keep the non values
else I want only the first letter of
lips only the first yeah the first
letter of the the cabin so I want to
have a value con to see how many how
many value of each deck I have oops
so now if I'm not interesting interested
sorry in having low values I could put
all of these so a F G and T in an other
likely belt labeled them at all other so
what I could do is use NP where so DF DF
Dec sorry equals and P dot where did I
write yeah where the deck is in a FG or
T so there is a dot easing function to
check that and we pass it just the lists
of values that we want to check so a F G
and T here so if my deck is in in is
equal to one of these values sorry I
should have put that up there then I
want to put I want to replace it with
other else I want just to keep the deck
and what I want to do is that is do a
get dummies
yes oh yeah yeah 15 yeah I think we're
fine thanks
so get them is will transform well will
not transform will give you for each of
the value of your colon it will create a
new colon and will put 0 and ones to
tell you if the value of this row was
like so for example what do we have see
or not will see like I'll it will be
easier if you see it probably it's not
that clear so we're gonna so that's
creating a new data frame so Dec
underscore dummies equals pandas dot get
underscore dummies and we're gonna pass
it the column that we want so DF deck
and we're gonna give it a prefix that it
will put at the beginning of each new
colon that it creates and our perfect
will be deck and then we can look at the
ads of this new data frame so deck
underscore dummies dot head not what it
looks like and it's easier to explain
when you have it here I'm sorry
okay and so so this one again created
one new : for the the values that we had
left in our deck : meaning b c d e and
other and each time it for each troy
will tell us okay so this one was a nun
because there are there was everywhere
this one was see this one was a nun this
one was see and so foreign and so on and
so forth and so on and so what we want
now because it's except it's a new data
frame what we want is concatenated with
our our original data frame so what can
I do
DF equal and look PD sorry dot con cards
and we're gonna pass it a list of data
frames that we want to concatenate so we
want to concatenate DF and the deck
dummies and we will give it access equal
1 because otherwise you will concatenate
regarding rows which won't be exactly
what we want to do meanings that we will
love like a a bigger data frame with
lots with lots and lots of nuns which is
not really what we want and if we check
with the DF dot shape and we can see
that now we have 22 Collins so we added
some here and there so like the lab
alized wand and
what yeah the family won the social one
and the 5 from the gate dummies so if we
want to drop Collins now some Collins
are not we wouldn't like are not gonna
be used because I get a message and I
will do the second part this afternoon
don't know like it's gonna be updated in
a schedule so for the machine learning
side we're not gonna use certain Collins
so we can drop Collins so we're gonna do
a to drop we're gonna give it a list of
Collins that we want to drop so name
[Music]
tickets cabin sex and barked and barked
and Dec and normally I have them there's
probably misspelling somewhere it would
be too fast too easy and oops what we're
gonna do is DF equals D F dot drop and
we're gonna pass it the list that we
just created so to drop and same the
axis because I think by default it's 0
and I put the bracket at the good place
will help up and so now like same if you
want to do a shape we know of only 16
columns
yes I'm not sure you can do that ah not
you can do that because I over yeah
because like here I the way I've done it
DF equals blah blah blah I've I have
over overwritten my data frame so that's
why usually this thing is here I don't
care and really I know I'm not gonna use
them anymore but otherwise the advice
would be give a new name like when you
want to keep your data frame and and
want to apply something to it's just
given I'll give another name creating
your objects yes can you what sorry oh
yeah I don't see why you wouldn't yeah
yeah you can I didn't do that because in
the sub setting like we could do we
could have like hero at least code you
can have a list comprehension you can
have like anything you could use a star
tweeze or like yeah yeah yeah you could
you okay one way to reorder your colon
if you want to do that oh that could be
another way to drop Cullen's like if you
wanna if you have a hundred columns and
you just want to keep 20 you can just
decide for a list of 20 and pass this
list to your data frame and then you
will just keep this these 20 Collins so
like for me was it was just to give an
example how to do that so just to avoid
having to type everything
just do idea that columns they will show
all my colons and the so just copy that
call lists that and the only thing I'm
gonna do is to move survived at the end
because I like it it's my target I like
to have it at the last column just
personal preference and we can just do
DF equals D F and past it ah-ha-ha-ha
whole list and if we do a heads we'll
see that just the first two ones oops
ah I was surprised not to put a queue
somewhere instead of a a here and we
have the survived colon which is at the
end okay so another one we can do is to
check out the correlation between the
numerical Cullen's so here because I
find it nicer I'm gonna do import c1 as
SNS and creates a correlation matrix for
my data frame
and I'm going to just display it as a
with it map vilela okay try again
so SNS dot it's map so my correlation
matrix and I'm just putting some other
parameters so red yellow green what is
it I'm a purist who writes GN not G or
at the end here it is
[Music]
so obviously the diagonal is super green
dark green because well it's all the
values are ones and the rest show us how
much correlated out a different
numerical well they're all numerical now
Cullens so we can see that's here which
makes sense socio and family are highly
correlated if you remember the way we
created them that makes complete sense
and if we want to look at subsets we can
also do just pass it a lists so double
square brackets if we look if we want to
look at family socio and all the likes
sips me like sibling and spa spouse and
the parent and children up
ah yep bad bad bad that's not gonna work
not a square bracket and dot core like
we what is it family I don't know why I
want to put up by another Wyatt family
we can see that there they are some of
them are already correlated because I'm
conscious of time so like the old out
what we would have to do here is to do
all the transformation that we've done
to our training set who would have to do
it to our old out we're not gonna have
time to do that right now but that's not
a big deal anyway everything like I've
saved another data frame so like if you
come this afternoon there won't be a
problem we're just gonna see how to save
a data frame um I'll just do that so I
can get collapsed there so if we want to
save D F we do D F dot do - sorry
underscore CSV and we pass it the the
pass where we want to save it so I
wanted to save it and don't and sorry in
the same folder as previously so data
slash Titanic
I'm slash my Titanic or whatever you
want to call it my tie time oh yeah time
Tom Nick dot CSV and we've saved our
data frame with all the changes okay
well it's noon so as I said like so
apparently I'm taking over someone this
afternoon so I'm gonna do the
in part I don't know which room but it
should be it will be updated on the
schedule and well no.5 is not a tutorial
room because 7 okay cool then well if
you wanna go on please come this
afternoon otherwise to you somewhere
wrong in the conference and have a good
lunch
[Applause]